PROFESSOR: Welcome back.
So in this session, we're
going to look at unit step
and impulse responses.
So in this question, we ask
you to find the unit impulse
response to these two equations,
x dot plus 2x equals f of t,
and 2 x dot dot plus 27 x
dot-- oops, it should be a 7--
plus 7 x dot plus
3x equals f of t.
In the second part, you're asked
to find the unit step response
for the first equation.
So here, the key
points are really
to remember what do we mean
by unit impulse and unit step
response.
Which initial condition
correspond to these responses?
And what functions of f of t
do you choose in each case?
So why don't you pause the video
and work through this problem?
And I'll be right back.
Welcome back.
So let's look at the equation
A. So the unit impulse response
is simply-- I'm going
to write this down,
unit impulse response--
is simply the solution
to the following problem, to
our differential equation,
x dot plus 2x that we're
given, with the forcing
in a delta function of magnitude
1 with rest initial conditions,
which means in this case,
that x of 0 is equal to 0.
x of 0 minus is equal to 0.
So how do we go about
solving this equation?
So here, first of all, let's
look at what this means.
This equation could be
modeling, for example,
the quantity of radioactive
chemical in a tank.
And delta(t) here means that we
are giving a high disturbance
on a very short
time on this system.
So for example,
dumping a huge amount
of chemical in that tank, and
then, just letting the system
evolve after dumping all
that chemical in a tank.
So really, what we could
see is that the delta
can be identified to x
dot, which is the highest
derivative in the system.
And that would then
mean that we have
a jump in the second
highest derivative, which
would be in x.
So delta t introduces
a jump in x.
And what do I mean by
that is that we had rest
initial conditions initially.
Now, we have to go into a jump
where the quantity in the tank
was raised to 1,
which is basically
the magnitude on the
right-hand side and the fact
that we have no
coefficients for the highest
derivative in the system.
So basically, we can
solve this equation
by solving the equivalent
problem x dot plus 2x equals
to 0, which is just
the homogeneous part,
with our new initial conditions,
x of 0 minus equals to 1.
And so here,
clearly from before,
we saw that the solution would
be a decaying exponential.
We would have a constant
of integration here, which
would be just 1 given our
new initial condition.
So this would be valid
for t larger than 0.
And given that we started from
rest initial conditions prior
to this perturbance
introduced by the delta,
we could also write this
with a u of t step function
if we were to consider
t in R. So if you
want to look at how the solution
looks like, we would have
basically rest
initial conditions,
and then, a jump
introduced by our forcing,
and after that, just a
decaying exponential,
and a jump here to a new
initial condition of 1.
So let's move to
the second problem.
Now, we're dealing with a
second-order differential
equation.
2 x dot dot plus 7 x dot
plus 3x equals f of t.
And we are asked again
to seek the unit impulse
response to this problem.
So the unit impulse response
is simply the solution of 2
x dot dot plus 7 x dot
plus 3x equals-- Again,
the unit impulse
means that we're just
kicking the system with an
impulse or delta function.
And we're starting from
rest initial conditions.
So here, let's just look at
what could this be modeling.
So this could be just
basically Newton's Second Law
with acceleration and forces
applied to the system.
For example, it could
be a mass hanged
on a spring with certain
damping due to this term.
And this delta here would
have basically the units
corresponding to a force that
would be felt by the highest
order of term in the integral
which could correspond
to the acceleration multiplied,
for example, by a mass of 2.
So really, the delta
can be identified
to the highest-order
derivative, which
means that we would have
a discontinuity from 0
to 1 on the derivative one
degree lower, so in x dot.
And so the delta introduces
the discontinuity
on the second
highest derivative.
And what I mean
by that is that we
have a jump from our
original initial conditions
of x dot 0 minus equals to
0 to new initial conditions,
x dot of 0 minus
equals one half.
Where did this one
half come from?
It came from the fact
that I have a factor of 2
in front of the
highest-order derivative.
So if I'm identifying
this with delta,
then integration of
this term would give me
an x dot that corresponds to
the jump from 0 to 1 over 2,
so one half.
That's where it comes from.
And each time that you would
have a coefficient in front
of your highest order
derivative associated
with the delta on the right,
you would have a jump of 1
over that coefficient.
So from this point,
what are we solving?
What do we need to solve to
get the unit impulse response?
It's equivalent to solving our
new system where we can then
get rid of the delta with
our new initial conditions,
dot equals one half.
And of course, here,
I did mentioned
by the initial condition on
x 0 minus 1, because we need
two initial conditions for
the second order derivative,
would still be 0, as the
discontinuity would not be
felt by the function x itself.
So we can go ahead and
solve this problem.
So we use the characteristic
polynomial as we did before.
This characteristic polynomial
would have a discriminant
of 25, which gives us simple
roots that we can compute,
so minus 7 plus or
minus the square root
of the discriminant over 4.
So we have two roots, minus
7 minus 5 over 4, minus 12
over 4, which is minus
3; minus 7 plus 5 over 4,
which just gives
us minus one half.
So we can write down the
solution to this problem
as c_1 exponential the
root that we just found,
minus 3t, plus c_2
exponential the other root,
minus one half of t.
Now, to get c_1, c_2, we
need to take into account
the initial conditions.
So the first one tells
us that x at 0 is 0.
So that will give us c_1
plus c_2 equals to 0,
so basically, c_2
equals minus c_1.
And the second initial
condition tells us
that the derivative is 0.
So that gives us minus 3c_1
minus one half c_2 equals to 0.
Here, we have that c_2
is equal to minus c_1.
So we can just factor
out everything.
And we end up with 3 minus
one half-- whoops, sorry.
Here it should be one half, our
new modified initial condition,
equals to one half.
And here, you would
have 5/2 equal to 1/2.
So c_2 equals 1/5
equals minus c_1.
And so plugging in c_1
and c_2 in this formula
would give us the
general solution
with c_2 exponential minus one
half t minus exponential minus
3t.
And all of this, remember, we're
solving for t larger than 0
in our modified system with
our new initial conditions.
So this is for t larger than 0.
And again, here, if we wanted
to just write it for t in R,
then we could just add
the step function u of t
that would just signify that
we took rest initial conditions
before x equals 0 minus.
So that ends the first part.
So now quickly, for
the second part,
we're asked to
find the unit step
response to the first system.
So the unit step
response is just
the solution to our original
ODE problem, x dot plus 2x.
But now, f of t is the step
function, hence, the step
here, with still rest
initial conditions.
So really, the step
function is just
0 everywhere before 0 minus.
And it takes the
value of 1 after.
And so basically, we
can just solve again
for t positive, the modified
differential equation with u
taking just the value of 1.
And here, we just
get similar roots.
So it would be a minus 2t.
But then, we would have
a constant of integration
to worry about.
And a new particular
solution, a lucky guess
would just be a constant.
And that would give us the
one half from 1 over 2.
So then, we just need to seek
the c_1 that would give us
x of t equals to 0 at 0.
Because in this
case, we don't need
to modify the
initial conditions.
They still remain the same,
rest initial conditions.
And so we would get here just
c_1 equals minus one half.
So we have 1 minus
exponential of minus 2t.
So just here, something
I forgot to mention,
what could this be modeling?
So this could be
modeling, if I go back
to my analogy of the radioactive
chemical in the tank,
this would be telling me
that after a certain time,
I start inputting
at a steady rate
at a constant rate of u of
t, of one per unit of time,
the amount in the tank
and then looking at how
the system evolves to that.
So there's no abrupt change
that introduces a discontinuity.
So just to conclude, I just
want to sketch the solution
just so that you see the
difference between the two.
And here, what we have, again, I
could have introduced my u of t
here if I want t
in R. So here, we
have again a solution
that is 0 before.
There is no discontinuity.
It's still 0 at 0 minus.
And then, we have
basically a solution
that is growing until it
reaches an asymptote of one half
when this exponential goes to 0.
And so you can see that it's
a smooth transition because I
just started
inputting the amount
of the chemical in the
tank in a non-abrupt way.
So this concludes this session.
And the key here was
to really remember
what do we mean by the
unit step response.
What type of f of t
are we talking about?
What initial
conditions do we need?
And same thing for the
unit impulse response.